Це бараки для смертників нацистського концтабору "Аушвіц-Біркенау"
під польським містечком Освенцім.
Сюди привозили ув’язнених жінок, які вже не могли працювати,
і тут вони чекали своєї черги до газової камери.
Серед них була і мати киянки Ніни Лебедєвої.
З роками все притупилося.
Але, як то кажуть, пробачити, як нам говорили, пробачити можна, але забути не можна.
Все, що було, все, як уві сні, крутиться.
Намагаюся нічого не згадувати.
І дітям ніколи не розповідала, поки вони не виросли.
Ніна Степанівна дивиться на гори взуття колишніх в’язнів концтабору.
Десь серед цих речей можуть бути і її.
Людей роздягали одразу, як вони прибували у концтабір.
Особисті речі, які сподобались есесівцям, вони забирали собі або своїм дітям.
Разом із мамою, сестрами і братом Ніна Степанівна потрапила сюди зовсім маленькою.
Мати і п’ятеро дітей: чотири доньки і син.
Старшій дівчинці було 11, брату було 9, Ніні було 5 і мені - 3.
Коли привезли в Освенцім, накололи номери, надягли робу, тут же розділили дорослих і дітей.
І, мабуть, ми востаннє бачили маму.
Потім нам одна жінка сказала, що її спалили в крематорії з малятком.
Чи-то вона захворіла, чи-то малятко, але в будь-якому разі їх спалили. Ми ж четверо вижили.
Віра і Ніна Лебедєви родом з-під Вітебська.
В "Аушвіц-Біркенау" потрапили у 1943-му.
Після звільнення Ніна Степанівна живе у Києві, а її сестра декілька років тому переїхала в Ізраїль.
У концтаборі їм пощастило не потрапити в руки так званого
"ангела смерті з Освенціма" Йозефа Менгеле -
лікаря, який ставив жахливі експерименти над ув’язненими.
Сестри кажуть, що нацисти відбирали дітей, схожих на арійську расу,
і маленькі Віра та Ніна теж потрапили у так званий донорський блок.
Коли відбирали нас від матері, нас замкнули у душовій, а з душової дітей у машину й вивозили.
Вивезли нас у Потуліце, у дитячий табір. Ми були у донорському блоці.
Там був й експериментальний блок,
а відбирали у донорський блок зі світлим волоссям, зі світлими очима дітей.
Кров брали. Але нам хоч нічого не вводили.
Тому ті, що повернулися, в основному - донорський блок.
Ті, що залишилися живими.
Ніна Степанівна показує свій концтабірський номер на руці - 65904.
А Віра Степанівна свій видалила - тепер шкодує.
Якось у 18 років один дурень мені сказав: як ти можеш ходити з фашистським тавром?
І я, як друга дурепа, пішла і видалила його.
Для сестер важливо, щоб наступні покоління не забували про жахіття,
які відбувалися у таборі смерті "Аушвіц-Біркенау",
де нацисти знищували людей у небачених доти масштабах.
За різними оцінками, тут отруїли у газових камерах,
а потім спалили у крематорії півтора мільйона людей.
Переважна більшість з них - євреї.
27 січня, дата визволення концтабору, нині Міжнародний день пам’яті жертв Голокосту.